certains d'entre vous le savent déjà
nous avons une femme qui vient étudier
dans cette classe seulement en tant
qu'observatrice
descendons dans les entrailles de
l'enfer si vous le voulez bien
il y a plus de possessions signalées de
nos jours que dans toutes les autres
époques de l'histoire nous devons
combattre pour sauver chaque âme
[Musique]
défendent dans le combat contre les
esprits de la malveillance
on vous sent pas bien Mathilde
regarder la bande-annonce
et angoisse c'est les promesses du film
donc à me sensible s'abstenir
on poursuit avec la conspiration du cœur
du réalisateur tariks a laissé le
thriller de la semaine il vous plonge en
plein conflit politique et religieux au
cœur de l'université islamique à Lazare
du Caire Adam fils de pêcheur réussit à
intégrer la prestigieuse université lieu
central du pouvoir de l'islam sunnite
une sorte de Harvard de du Coran mais
lorsque le grand imam a la tête de cette
institution décès de le jour même de la
rentrée Adam va se retrouver à son insu
en plein milieu d'une guerre d'influence
pour trouver son successeur c'est un
film à suspense un thriller d'espionnage
à l'intrigue complexe prix du scénario à
Cannes qui jetera qui vous tiendra en
haleine jusqu'à la dernière image deux
films un peu sombre il y a aussi la
comédie Céline
on va possède une comédie française
l'équipe de barbecue et de retour pour
plancha Derrick Laven pour ce nouveau
film on prend les mêmes ou presque et on
recommence Lambert Wilson Franck Dubosc
Guillaume de ton carrec et Jérôme
Commandeur reviennent donc après 8 ans
après les Cévennes du premier opus
direction la Bretagne où nos compères se
réjouissent de fêter les 50 ans de leur
ami Yves avec les Landes à perte de vue
les vieilles pierres les plages de sable
fin le fest-noz tout est en apparence
prévue pour un séjour
idyllique sauf bien sûr Bretagne
Bretagne oblige et ben le beau temps qui
n'est pas présent sur Youtube c'est
comme d'habitude
urbaines c'est une légende urbaine et
donc sur place la cohabitation s'annonce
un petit peu compliqué les amis de
toujours pourrait bien se brouiller lors
d'importantes révélations on va regarder
aussi un extrait de la bande-annonce
vous inquiétez pas c'est la Bretagne il
y a toujours plein de trucs à faire la
palourde se situe à la limite du sable
sec mais
tu fais quoi maintenant je me suis
inscrite à un cours de sculpture
tu travailles toujours pas quoi
je me suis fait piquer par le guêpe une
guêpe en Bretagne vise ma couille
qui s'est fait piquer au parti comme toi
il a gonflé gonflé gonflé et il est mort
et enfin dernier film pour les plus
jeunes peut-être l'école est à nous une
comédie signée Alexandre Castagnetti
alors autour de cette table qui n'a
jamais rêvé de pouvoir faire ce qu'il
voulait à l'école et bien eux ils l'ont
fait alors l'histoire se centre autour
d'une professeur de mathématiques un peu
excentrique qui va profiter d'une grève
générale dans un collège pour tenter un
concept inédit donné à ses élèves cartes
branches et leur laisser faire ce qu'ils
veulent c'est un film qui questionne
l'éducation et l'école avec humour et
optimisme vous préférez quel film autour
de cette table
et vous Céline d'horreur du coup non non
toujours pas d'horreur moi je dirais
peut-être effectivement l'école est à
nous ouais il y a des belles valeurs qui
sont qui sont discutées non je pense que
ça et vous du coup
j'aime beaucoup Franck Dubosc